hello everybody and welcome to part 5 of
our flask tutorial video series in this
video we're going to be talking about is
kind of adding a few more things mainly
the right navigation bar to this page
and this will be kind of the last major
use major kind of explanation of
bootstrap elements as far as the
methodology for you know copying and
pasting I think it's a pretty simple
methodology to understand so I'll still
continue to explain at least the origins
of the code and kind of point you to it
but this is kind of a slow slow way of
going through it so I just now that you
hopefully understand how we're doing it
you'll be able to mimic it as well so
moving right along we've got this so far
and we need this kind of right-hand
navigation bar so if we come here we've
got various things like for example if I
log out here we can click signup and
that pops up with a little cute thing
here we can hit login that pops up with
some login stuff and so on so we kind of
want to mimic that then obviously we
need the video we're pretty much done of
course we still want to add a footer and
actually an improved footer from this
I've updated my footer so well you'll
have the new and improved code soon
anyway let's get started so we want to
add this and the first of all it's
called a nav bar right and so for
example we'll come over to try to think
of which one that I think it being
components will do ctrl F and we're
looking for a nav bar right now sure
enough and basically click and highlight
everything I think it's up to this
unordered list copy that and then we'll
come over to still within our header so
down here and paste and just check
indeed that's correct
and let's tab this over left so shift
tab oh that's odd okay nevermind control
I get are my eyes play I guess what you
just need
bump this one over a little bit okay
okay but hold on I have to fix this yeah
oh no I hit it too many times hold on
this is pretty bad Wow is it okay it's
like the tabs are just too much or
something I don't know having a really
hard time here we'll just do this you
guys can feel free to fix on your own
time let's save I don't want to waste
anyone's time here we save that refresh
and here's our bar now it's a a little
low low here are we not within the same
let me see here so okay so with these
we'll leave that here in its own little
div tag but now we're actually let's
make a div around here so we're going to
say div and then class equals container
- fluid that's a Sierra that's a
bootstrap code for a fluid container
that kind of moves around just you can
also use your straight container it's a
little more fixed and that div tag now
there within the same div so let's save
that and hopefully uh still tabbing down
and quite sure why um let's see let me
go back up here header head writer
everything's within the header we've got
this div a that makes sort of sense why
that would tab it down but not enough to
cause this problem and then div
container fluid oh well probably mmm
this is prior problem actually so let's
let's get rid of that real quick let me
save that let's try that one more time
now yeah that was our problem okay uh so
now we'll zoom in here and we can see
that obviously when we zoom it still
causes some trouble you'll notice that
with bootstrap you'll have stuff like
this and then you'll do this and you can
kind of like leave it kind of messed up
and like
it's kind of annoying and you are free
to try to fix little stuff like that but
how many people are coming to your
website and doing like this like
squishing it and then bringing it back
like like if you want to fix that go for
it a not really top priority in my book
so I'm not going to worry too much about
that that drop down still does not work
but I'll show you in this video how to
make that work and in fact I can
probably show you right now just before
we replace that drop down so we come
down here outside of the header you're
going to have things called body tags
and this is where the actual body of
your stuff goes this is also where the
Python generated content is tending to
go and within that what we're going to
do is we're going to have some script
tags and generally a script tag looks
like the following so you've got like
this here you'll do this and so here's a
script tag it's text slash JavaScript
and then this is the you know path to
that and then we'll do the exact same
thing again we'll come down here and
this is an outsourced code for jQuery
and so this is the code that we were
housing on our website so it's within
the static directory the file name is in
this j/s slash bootstrap Minjae s and
then this is jQuery so we can save this
come to our website refresh and the drop
down should work it's not working still
very aggravating let me see it's kind of
confusing why that that that shouldn't
done it
is there nothing in the drop-down nope
there's stuff there let's see if we're
missing elements bootstrapped
yeah well we're seeing yes so whenever
something doesn't work you can always
you know hit f12 and that brings up
these like little developer tool things
and then you can see the air that's
coming
it says bootstrap requires jQuery no
problem I understand that good sir we
are report or we are importing jQuery
let us let's bring it in on top instead
however let's try to save that so before
bootstrap now okay that worked okay so
it was our problem it just wasn't coming
first understandable so now the
drop-down works anyway moving on we're
actually not going to choose those
dropdowns instead we're gonna have a
modal here but you could use them I
don't think they look bad honestly but
we're going to add those modal's that I
use currently so we'd have this and then
now we're basically going to gut all
that we just wanted the nav bar really
and now what we want is to use these
modal's so this will probably the last
time I really show you guys anything but
I wanted to show you guys just so we're
taking that bar right we want that but
now we want the modal and the modal's
are going to be in probably component so
let's type modal no I get I guess it
would be JavaScript out let's try that
okay here we are right so here's some
code that will give us this button and
launch so this would be the path I would
take I would just copy that code over
here paste it let's let me zoom out real
quick and fix the orientation a bit save
come back to my website refresh lookie
there
we'll hit launch demo modal and sure
enough it works so we're like yeah
that's cool we want to use that so we
close so we know we want it we don't
really want the button though but that's
okay we can change that to be anything
we want
so for example what I'm going to do is
we'll come over I think what I'll do is
I'll take
I think if I want to yeah I guess we'll
just leave that there and then what we
can do is we can come over to here and I
let's just ctrl F modal it's not really
the best let's see navbar right so
that's this is that our nap you know UL
class navbar right and then we can take
that all the way down to I'm trying to
see the closing tags for my that's our
all the way down here here we are okay
so you can come to my website and I
would just copy and paste it and I'll
explain the code that's within that
we're actually using but copy that come
over here there may be some variables
but should be able to get away with this
so unordered let let me check one last
is the unordered list all the way up to
unordered lists yeah so we're going to
copy this come on down paste will save
real quick and see if get away with this
let me refresh okay so there's our
buttons we could login sure enough
there's the login we click sign up then
we go let me go
a I'll be right back
okay I assure you no animals were harmed
in the making of this video
so apparently someone had a fire
something out sighs a fire truck and
everything uh brighten my house it's
actually burning down right now as I'm
making the video anyway my dogs trying
to alert me okay so so this is our web
site we copy and pasted the code I just
want to explain kind of what what my
code is I don't really want to just copy
and paste a bunch of stuff and be like
are you'll figure it out but you should
be able to kind of gather from what
we're doing here so this was our
original navbar right what's happening
here is we've got now a container within
it that container has basically all of
the stuff and this is our modal I
actually apparently left the original ID
tag even so what happens with a modal is
first we have a link here that's just
support and donate so this is probably
the most easy one to understand so I'll
explain that one first so you have this
here and this is just a typical link and
then you see we have this edition of
spam and then this glyph icon and then
support and then these weird symbols and
what it's doing is we're linking to the
support page so that's here we click on
that and it'll send us to the support
page then we have span and what this
does is generate that glyph icon then we
come over here to support and that's
just the text of the button basically
and then these these things all these
are like spaces so a lot of times you
can add your own space but it only will
like one space is one space you can't
just like space space space restiveness
it will treat just a bunch of spaces
like one space but you can use these and
it'll be many spaces also I added a
space here because without it I don't
know it's just too close to the glyph
icon so I'll just show you really quick
I just I feel like it's too close I want
a space so anyway I have the space so
that's a basic link now we're going to
incorporate the link with a glyph I or a
link that will call upon a modal so here
we have a link that calls upon this
modal here and so here let's just
address this a role present
tation don't really need to worry too
much about that class active uh we don't
actually even need I'm not sure that's
actually been necessary honestly let's
just refresh real quick I don't I don't
really see that there's any need for
that these underlines are ugly too we'll
get rid of those I'm super I don't
understand how they're they're on anyway
well we'll get rid of this you can add a
pretty simple code to get rid of those
well I guess we'll add that in the next
one I just want explain this code real
quick so anyways this links to that
modal the data target data toggle needs
to be modal data target is you know the
pound sign and then whatever the name or
the ID of that modal is so you can even
see I highlight this and in its exact
same as this one and that's how this
modal will know when I click on this the
data target is that modal which just so
happens this is the thing that has that
ID what is that thing as that ID it's a
modal fade which is bootstrap code
awesome and whatever's in within this
div tag is what will load and that's
basically it
I mean so what's in this div tag is it's
a modal dialog content header this is
all stuff that is within JavaScript here
so you can just see that these are
basically all the stuff and you can
click on that this is text in a modal
the modal title is something that goes
up here before this divider you can put
buttons in here a bunch of text they
came with some buttons I don't really
use them I don't really see the point of
having the Xbox and a closed but
whatever uh anyway all that so it's all
just basically bootstrap code that we've
copy and pasted honestly the only thing
that might be somewhat confusing is the
forms here is including this form this
is a form that we're actually going to
use that is generated by flask so right
now it's going to have to be one of
those things that I'm going to have to
explain kind of more in detail later but
it will be explained so it's a form that
is
basically kind of checked by pythons so
when someone fills out a form you need
to make sure the form one is kind of
secure you need to take that data pass
that data and store it and it needs to
be all done in Python code but in a very
fancy and secure way also when you have
like say registration form
let's come to our website for example
and say somebody comes here and they
click on signup you need to make sure
the username needs to be a username that
doesn't exist the email address kind of
needs to be a legit email address
password and password need to match each
other they need to have accepted the
Terms of Service and then they are
allowed to register but only when all of
those chips and all those stars align
can somebody register so obviously
that's important so the signup
registration form is kind of a unique
form so anyways that's that hopefully
you understand everything up to this
point I tried to pick up the pace a
little bit and we'll continue kind of
picking up the pace with HTML and stuff
so if you do have any questions though
please don't feel stupid or silly asking
for help I'm always happy to help I'm
sure other people will be happy to help
if you're confused about something check
out the documentation for bootstrap a
lot of good stuff to learn there and I
think that's it so again if you have
questions or comments leave them below
otherwise as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until the next video